das ist eine echte premiere auf der sehr
sehr viel hoffnung und erstmals in der
geschichte der hiv forschung werden
gleich vier verschiedene impfstoff
konzept den studien getestet fachleute
sind zuversichtlich dass ein effektiver
hiv impfstoff bereits in zwei jahren
2021 eingesetzt werden könnte wird aids
so endlich ausgelöscht klicks um
science-fiction gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
deaktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasste nichts los gehts richtig
willkommen von dem so genannten 90 90 90
ziel der vereinten nationen sind wir
noch weit entfernt demnach müssten wir
in der lage sein 90 prozent der
hiv-infektionen zu diagnostizieren
die 90 prozent der der diagnostizierten
zu therapieren und bei 90 prozent der
behandelten die virus menge im blut so
reduzieren so dass diese hiv nicht mehr
übertragen könnten laut prognose könnte
zum jahr 2070 noch immer etwa 1,6
millionen neuinfektionen mit hiv geben
ohne impfstoff doch genau an dieser
stellschraube tüfteln forschungsteams
weltweit derzeit sind es sogar vier
verschiedene impfstoff konzepte die sich
gleichzeitig im test befinden
das ist einmalig in der geschichte der
hiv forschung und auch enorm wichtig
denn eine infektion mit hiv viren kann
bis heute trotz intensiver forschung
nicht geheilt werden auch wenn es
medikamente gibt die das virus im
menschlichen körper unterdrücken und
zumindest den ausbruch von aids
verhindern
der bonner wissenschaftler hendrik
strikt vom institut für hiv forschung
setzt große hoffnung auf die entwicklung
eines effektiven impfstoffes in der
nahen zukunft denn einen erreger
auszurotten das sei bislang nur mit
hilfe eines impfstoffs gelungen wie das
beispiel der puppen zeige und so ist er
auch bezüglich einer hiv impfung
optimistisch mit einem nur 70% ich
wirksamen impfstoff könnten wir eine
reduktion auf 250.000 neuinfektionen pro
jahr erreichen statt 1,6 millionen
neuinfektionen also nur 250.000 das wäre
wirklich einen riesenfortschritt eine
hiv impfstoff studie läuft unter der
bezeichnung hv tl
72 sie basiert auf einem impfstoff rv
144 der sich in einer klinischen studie
in thailand vor zehn jahren 2009 zwar
als wirksam aber nicht als nachhaltig
genug herausgestellt hatte immerhin
hatte der impfstoff dazu geführt dass
die rate der hiv-infektionen um etwa 30
prozent seien der nachfolgekandidaten
wurde 2016 in südafrika eingeführt und
soll einen zitat größeren und
nachhaltigeren schutz bieten als das rv
144 schema und wurde an dem im südlichen
afrika vorherrschen hiv subtyp angepasst
so die angaben des nationalen instituts
für allergie und infektionskrankheiten
in den usa hinter dieser sogenannten
hamburg studie steckt die pharmafirma
sanofi außerdem am start die pharmafirma
merck mit der sogenannten im budo studie
in der alle subtypen von hiv abgedeckt
werden sollen auch sie wird
hauptsächlich im südafrikanischen
ländern durchgeführt und zwar an 2600
frauen in dieser gegend sind vor allem
heterosexuelle frauen stark gefährdet
und das ist wirklich ziemlich krass die
infektionsrate bei frauen zwischen 18
und 25 jahren liegt hier bei weit über
50 prozent bei mehr als jede zweite frau
bekommt als die ersten ergebnisse werden
in drei jahren 2022 erwartet dazu der
hiv forscher henrik strikt erste
versuche bei affen haben eine
schutzwirkung von 67 prozent gezeigt die
erwartungen der fachleute sind hoch denn
der impfstoff könnte auch beim menschen
eine ähnlich gute immunantwort auslösen
dieses impfstoff prinzip wurde
weiterentwickelt und wird derzeit in der
sogenannten mosaike studie getestet in
texas wurde der erste proband überhaupt
geimpft und zwar mitte november 2009 10
seit dezember läuft die studie auch in
polen italien und spanien werden noch
folgen insgesamt nehmen 3800
homosexuelle männer und transsexuelle
teil und zwar an 57 standorten in europa
und den usa
bei tierversuchen mit affen konnten
diese impfstoffe eine schutzwirkung
insgesamt von 94 prozent erzählen das
ist wirklich damals doch sowohl die in
buckow als auch die mosaik rohstoffe
sind nicht ohne
dazu susan buchbinder vom ei
forschungsprogramm in san francisco
keiner dieser impfstoffe ist
besonders einfaches verfahren also wird
es einen ziemlichen aufwand erfordern
sie einzusetzen
sie erfordern mehrere injektionen so
dass jede von ihnen in ihrer jetzigen
konfiguration mindestens vier
verschiedenen dosen benötigt doch klar
ist auch wenn die fachleute ist jetzt
schaffen einen wirksamen impfstoff zu
entwickeln könnte dieser durch weitere
forschung zukünftig auch einfacher und
effektiver gestaltet werden
der vierte im stoff heißt back und wird
erst seit kurzer zeit getestet und zwar
in südafrika tansania mosambik und
uganda verabreicht wird der impfstoff
mit den treppen die einen schutz vor der
infektion bieten sollen bis die wirkung
des impfstoffes greift erst in vier
jahren 2023 sollen hier die ersten
ergebnisse veröffentlicht werden
die gute nachricht in diesem
zusammenhang medikamente wie die prep in
gemen die verbreitung schon ein brett
steht für die exposition prophylaxe also
übersetzt so viel wie vor sorge vor
einem möglichen hiv kontakt die therapie
führt dazu dass die virus menge im blut
stark reduziert wird und die viren nicht
mehr nachweisbar sind bei menschen ohne
hiv viren im blut sorgt das präparat
dafür dass sie sich gar nicht ausbreiten
können und sich die menschen so gar
nicht erst anstecken egal wer es nimmt
der infizierte oder der nicht infizierte
sexualpartner
es besteht keine ansteckungsgefahr mehr
doch diese gute nachricht gilt nicht
weltweit vor allem in einigen ländern
zentralafrikas osteuropas und asiens
sind die trefferchance programme nicht
ausreichend im schlimmsten fall droht
hier eine komplett neue epidemie so die
befürchtung einiger fachleute nie mehr
aids hier gibt es noch mehr infos über
prep anklicken anschauen und klicks um
science-fiction abonnieren wer es noch
nicht getan hat jetzt wird es aber
wirklich höchste zeit also bis dann
bleibt dran